hello everyone and welcome to another
game from round two of the 20/20
candidates tournament it's Maxine
gaushala gravure seceding leerin Maxine
had a very nice game yesterday against
Fabi we already checked out that game
that ended in a draw but the ding
started the tournament with a loss and
well he definitely wants to bounce back
and get back into this tournament so
what happens here well let's let's just
check it out we do have a nice photo of
the match up here we can see Maxime it's
still a position from the opening ding
either not psyched about the game or
still maybe thinking about his loss
yesterday but could be a lot of other
things as well or maybe it's just uh you
know a photo that that's captured in a
you know perhaps not in not an optimal
moment but either way just get into the
mood for the game and also I've prepared
at their head-to-head score which I
don't know I kind of think you might be
interested in those so in classical
games as you can see maxime beaugeois
graphic design in classical and if you
include rapid and exhibition games Maxie
Marshall aggravated England 12 to 5 so
in both classical and faster time
formats Maxime has has an edge against
ding leerin so let's see let's see what
happens here Maxime with the white
pieces opens with E for that we've 5
biding Knight f3 Knight to c6 and again
in Bishop to b5 Maxine was for the rule
opus with a 6 more fees defense Bishop
to a4 and the knight to f6 now now we
have castles Bishop to e7 and rook to e1
with b5 all standard stuff Bishop to b3
and now castles and here h3 not are not
going for c3 and allowing some Marshall
positions to to arise so h3 and Bishop
to b7 biding with D 3 d 6 and now a3 and
making room for the light square bishop
if let's say something like Knight to a5
is played at the make room for the C
pawn we have Queen to d7 biding and now
Knight to c3 continuing development and
rook F to e 8 and here Maxima decided to
go for Bishop to d2
it's a move that has been played before
a few times but I've never never has a
white achieved more than a draw with
this idea from notable games even charge
versus and meet Recife to screen was
played in 2015 the game ended in a draw
but ok
Knight to d8 biding now making room for
the C pawn but also with ideas of
shifting this Knight over to e 6 and now
there there are no moves Knight the h2
is a known move and also nice to e 2 is
a known move but here Maxime goes for
Knights the d5 and this is what he
prepared for this game
so as of move 13 we have a completely
new game and here Dean has to decide
whether he wants to mess up White's pawn
structure and by capturing on d5 or he
wants to continue with let's say 96
captures captures and play this position
having access to maybe f4 and d4 squares
so both ideas have their merits but
dingos for Knight characters on d5 and
okay we have 8 captors on d5 and now the
position is such that White has a double
D pawn and also the light square bishop
isn't doing all that much now but Maxime
wouldn't do this if he didn't prepare
something you know probably so c5 here
biding c6 is also an idea you might want
to get rid of this d5 pawn here it does
seem like a nuisance for example if c4
you could go captures captures and then
f6 strengthening the position and then
you could use maybe the open C file for
your rook but the thing is it decides to
go for c5 for a very specific reason he
wants to have this option of playing c4
as he wants to play f5 and playing f5
without the inclusion of this c4 c5 c 4
idea doesn't work because if F 5 then
just Knight captures an e5 if this night
or if this point was still here and then
you have this discovery checking the
black ink so here we have a 4 trying to
bust open the position and now f5 and
this is what ding was planning now the
same idea with Knight chapters and in
fact doesn't work because after captures
you have this check but now being has c4
with the inclusion of c5 the
actress and Bishop to f6 now and here
even after even with best play let's say
eight chapters and v5a characters a
trade of rooks characters captors and
now see characters and b5 Bing would
have a very nice spawn here on d6 and
also a very nice pawn here on unbe 5 the
the black king is in check you have to
move it now let's say Bishop to b4 and
defending the pawn and it's a
complicated position but the ending
should be better there is no real
compensation for the piece although
those pawns do look scary for example
you cannot capture the point here
because if d7 then the rook has no
squares the the bishop pair is extremely
strong here
so after f5 maxime knows that he can't
play this but there is a move that he
can play and it's such a it's hard to
say I didn't catch an interview but it's
hard to say if he's still in preparation
or was this a move that happened over
the board but I know it wasn't played
like instantly he played a capture son
b5 a characterís rock character special
characters and now c4 c4 is extremely
strong because you're just threatening
to win a pawn and there doesn't seem to
be anything Dean can do about it if you
capture the ship to a4 just wins the
game you either have to move the Queen
and lose a whole rook or you have to
give up the night here and then just
capture seer you're gonna capture the
knight on the next move it's completely
winning for Maxine so after the c-4 move
dingoes Knight to the f7 reinforces e5
and he says ok there's there's time for
four other things because there's
nothing I can do about the b5 point and
Maxime just captures it be characters
see captures on b5 so what happens now
again you cannot capture because of well
you just lose the game here okay not so
not right away
but you will lose the exchange and after
that you don't really have anything to
show for it you will lose this against
Maxine
so instead after C capture son b5 being
played g5 and what what's going on here
of course he wants to play g-force start
an attack against the White King and say
ok your your one pawn the the
really do anything on the queenside I'm
gonna attack on the kingside problem is
it's not Maxime to move so you can even
feel feel free to pause the video if
you're interested what you would play as
white here if Dean was coming for you
so feel free to do it while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who found it and it is the move machine
played congratulations and for those who
just want to enjoy the show
Knight to h2 is the move as it prevents
G for now if G for you just trade
everything you don't really care even
with the check that you have to trade
queens and then you're just up to pawns
not much black can do about this so
that's one thing you've prevented G for
but also you can infiltrate with Queen
to h5 which can also be pretty
unpleasant so here we have kink the g7
biding he wants to bring the king over
to g6 now and we have Bishop the c4 now
just strengthening the pawns here so you
no longer have to worry about that b5
whenever again and you have a past b5
point for the rest of the game and also
b4 is coming which will be which will be
a very strong move with King to g6
biding now not allowing Queen h5 also
with ideas of h5 maybe but now G for
stopping Age 5 and also asking are you
prepared to open up the position with
your King still on g6 and thing is if
captures captures then it's very
difficult for black to activate any of
the pieces this Bishop not doing
anything the Queen due to the g4 pawn
not really able to do anything
the knight also not not not not the
greatest of pieces you're just gonna go
Knight if one night g3 to f5 place your
knight there and then you can even do
something like Queen a four to A six B
six maybe push the pawn later on
well basically and so on so it would be
very dangerous to capture it so instead
night the h6 biding and now reinforces
f5 but now Queen to f3 puts more
pressure on f5 and here that you could
block the position completely we'd have
four but then you allow Quinta efore
check and night is coming to f3 it could
be it could be very ugly so you maybe
maybe should postpone something like
this until you have to play it so first
Bishop
he knows that before his coming and he
wants to be ready with this Bishop to b6
move also the rook will now be able to
help out along the e-file we have
cleaned the g2 now Maxime has ideas of
capturing on a5 and then both of the
Queen and the bishop will be eyeing that
g5 pawned the knight can come to f3 to
help out with the attack h4 can be
played so a lot of pressure with dings
King still being on g6 so here it's
extremely difficult to find the move for
black so basically you can choose an
active move likely being chose hitting
played f4 here but if you play a slow
move like better up to b7 you just wait
and see what White has in stored then
it's Bishop e7 might actually be the
best move for ding even though it's not
much it's just waiting but the point is
after G captures on f5 you know with
check you're gonna play Queen captures
on f5 and then you're gonna lose the
game terribly because after f4 you
cannot capture with this because your
route Kang is you cannot capture with
the Jeep on because well there's just
the pin you cannot capture with the
Queen Bishop guards that and then
whatever you play let's say Bishop c8
you're just gonna play F capture sin g5
pulls back in the night and then h4 and
so on it's much much better for white so
the point is after Bishop to b7 and a
continuation that's extremely difficult
to find G captures on f5 and now not
capturing but instead night capture and
not capturing with a queen but rather
with the night and then after Knight to
f3 putting more pressure here King to g7
this is the key move you have to find
the point is if white goes after the
pawn with the knight and the bishop you
have King h8 and then you bring the rook
over to g8 and harass white along the G
file but it's still very difficult after
h4 you're gonna play King Day h8
characters and g5 and here you have this
position where white is up 2 points but
it's an incredibly crazy position where
why it should be better on all accounts
but in a practical game over the board
it's hard to say what can happen but
definitely Bishop to d7 with just
wasting a move checking if white will go
for this with the idea of King G 7 h8
and rook g8 maybe maybe dings best idea
or maybe King g7 right away point is you
have to wait and see what white will do
but instead the ding went for f4 and now
like we said this allows the screen to
e4 maneuver so Maxime continued with b4
it's a move that has to be played you of
course have to bust open the position
here being played Bishop to b6 and now
once again feel free to pause the video
and try to find the winning move for
Maxime while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who are able
to do it congratulations on spotting
that well if Queen comes to e4 and then
the rook Queen along the e-file are her
will be x-raying that rock on e8 and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's either captures on c5 or
queenie for Czech it's the same line
only a different move order so either
you capture and then queenie for Czech
or you play queenie forecheck like
Maxime did and then you capture on c5 so
King g7 b captures on c5 and now you
have problems if bishop characters d4 is
incredibly strong again you cannot
capture because the rook hangs you have
to capture with the bishop but now
Knight f3 threatening to capture here
again you will not be able to recapture
because the rook hang so King f8
defending the rook but now Bishop to b4
again with a lot of pressure now the you
will not be able to recapture here so
rook the e7 now knife characters n e5 is
no longer threat but now Queen d3 also
one of the one of the nice things about
playing before is that you freed the d3
square for the Queen and now g5 hangs if
you defend it for example with knight of
seven then quinta h7 is an idea and
there's just not much you can do about
this for example if you go in defending
white can't play pretty much anything
Queen to a3 is the cleanest way to
finish it off as it comes up with a
double attack against the bishop and the
d6 pawn black can simply can't keep keep
an eye on everything so instead after
this B captors and c5 ding didn't go for
Bishop captures but for D captors on c5
and now
maxime just continues Knight to f3 puts
more pressure here on the g5 pawn Knight
the f7 now guarding both of these points
and Bishop the c3 now again putting more
pressure here Bishop the c7 defending
and now be 6 by Maxine beautiful move
again if you capture it's it's not a
it's not well it's not the greatest move
for black because you no longer defend
on e5 and after characters CalPERS with
check King to g8 you have d6 again
opening up a discovery the bishop pair
is just beautiful here for for Maxime
even though dink has a bishop pair as
well although it's not as operational as
a mock seems a bishop pair King f8
you're gonna go Bishop to g7 check crazy
move of course if Queen captures then
Queen captures on EI tis mate
so King would have to capture but then
you just go into the same game which is
of course completely winning it's not
just that you're out the exchange you
are completely winning as d7 d8 is
unstoppable is Bishop c6 you just play
d7 and after captures check and you pick
up well the bishop and you are you are
down the whole rook
so after b6 of course you cannot capture
the dink played Bishop to be 8 and now
Maxime could keep the pressure with rook
to be one threat and b7 but he decides
that it's no longer needed he can just
trade Queens now and go into an endgame
here so ding trades with Queen captures
because now there's well there's a
double attack here there's there's a
quadruple attack on on e5 not much you
can do about that so ding decides the
trade and here King f6 and it seems like
a ding is defending everything but
Maxime has something to say about that
Knight to be 2 now he wants to get the
night over to e4 to deliver check and if
you force the King to capture on f5 it
could be could be very unpleasant
although this might actually be the best
way for the I'm just gonna show a line
it's extremely complicated but such
things are normal when two super
grandmasters play a super prepared
engine line of course there are a lot of
poisonous ideas in the position for
example if King captures an f5 Bishop to
b5 attacking the rook here you move the
rook and now Bishop to c6 hoping for
black to capture and you will get two
connected passed pawns but of course the
black not interested Bishop d7 now the
regards the bishop and now Knight to c4
you're gonna play something you don't
all that many moves with black h5 you're
gonna go rook the a1 let's say G four
characters captures you're gonna go rook
the a5 you're gonna pick up this pawn
you're gonna be up upon and then
probably probably end up winning the
game but it still it still could get
ugly for example f3 rook captures and c5
you're gonna go Knight to d6 rook the a5
getting the rock out of the way and now
II four so let's say Knight character
son v6 with Czech Bishop characters in
the group the a7 with a double attack on
the bishop now black could try even III
so I'm just showing how rich the
position is for example if you give up
the piece even it captures and if you
check is an idea and now you don't want
to capture here and allow ideas like
rook to eat you check Bishop to c5 check
so you have to play King to f1 and then
a lot of crazy ideas are possible
Bishop to c8 you don't want to allow
that because then the point just
advances so you have to block it but
still let's say Bishop c6 rookie - and
it's it's a really crazy position what
is of course better but if you allow
something like Bishop here and let's say
something like this then white is just
done for so that's what what you know
the position holds if you play King
captures an f5 ding decides against it
ding plays the rook to d8 instead now
going for this pawn here but maxime just
continues with d6 he gives up the pawn
but on d6 he wants the free of this
diagonal and also the d5 square for his
Bishop as you'll see so Dean captures
the pawn and the now comes rook to be
one threatening b7 and here there are
two ideas you could go for best of the
c6 is one of them not allowing your
Bishop to be trapped after b7 but then
you allow night Stewie for check which
kind of will pick up your rook so you
will have to give up the bishop here and
then again not much you can do here with
black you could try h5 but then b7 and
after let's say g4 captures captures
you're still gonna go for rook to a1
rook the b6 you go after the pawn but
now Bishop to d5 guarding the pawn next
you're gonna go look to a8 and it should
be should be winning for white so after
Luke to be won but Bishop to c6 as you
can see and not really
great so adding says well let's just
prevent this point from ever being
pushed here he goes the night to d8 but
now once again for the final time feel
free to pause the video and you know
finish this game once and for all
well I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting that the
point actually must be pushed as you all
know passports must be pushed and for
those of you who just wanna enjoy the
show its b7 the move ding set out to
stop now is you know the move that
causes his undoing
so problem is if you capture it let's
say with the knight Knight captures on
b7 then you go 94 check of course the
better no longer has access to e4 King
characters Knight captures with Czech
Knight captures and now you pick up the
bishop here and well let's say captures
captures you're just up a whole look
completely winning endgame for white
so after b-17 decided to go for Bishop
captures and b7 but now the movie of
course saw once you found b7 is Bishop
to a5 simply attack the defender of the
bishop on b7 and now the threat is I
pick up the night next I pick up the
bishop or if you move the bishop I pick
up the dark square bishop so whatever
you do you're losing a piece here
there's nothing more to be done here and
in more 37 it was in this position that
Dingley ruin resigned the game and
incredible as it is
dinkler and starts the 20/20 candidates
tournament with zero out of two which is
just incredible and I've seen a lot of
you in the comments asking how is this
possible and it does it have to do
something with with the coronavirus and
everything well it's hard to say but
it's one of the reasons they motor job
of said that he will not be playing the
tournament because he said if if 99th of
99 percent of my mental capacity it goes
towards the chess game and only 1% of my
mental capacity is worrying about
anything else in the chess world but my
family about me me me catching the virus
about anything then that's no longer me
at my best and it could be that this is
what happ what happens to ding here
because in a lot of moments in a lot of
moments ding had better options and
well it's it's very unlikely that
someone who can go over a hundred games
undefeated in classical chess
we'll start with a zero out of two for a
tournament he's basically been preparing
for the last three months but yeah yeah
Maxime is also kind of a wild card here
and no one actually expected him to be
here so no one probably prepared for him
and he will be able to surprise a lot of
players so it should be should be
extremely interesting but we're gonna
show at least one more game from round
two and then we're gonna discuss the
standings a bit more but yeah as usual
I'm always interested what are your
thoughts on this and do you think ding
will be able to bounce back and is he
still a contender to win because if you
remember in the last candidates
tournament being played out through the
entire tournament without a single loss
and he still wasn't able to clinch first
place but you know it's still early
we'll see what happens
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank
Federico tamagotchi for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous video Sarah thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the feeder
candidates tournament 2020 and well
whatever else we we manage the time for
maybe on a rest day or something like
that so I think y'all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day